assalamu aleikum walekum - over here -
prophets and sisters and dear friends
non-muslim and Muslim if you're not
Muslim you're new to my channel
subscribe with for many videos this is
the place and the platform which you can
learn what Islam really teaches from the
right place
not from bigots or a stammer folks it's
a right place to be so thank you coming
to my channel if you haven't seen my
debate with Tom Robinson do go and check
that out it's on my channel
coming back to now today's video I'm
gonna do is my summary now Tom Robinson
did is someone on this very same night
maybe he found the need to do it because
he couldn't answer my question which was
but killing of innocent people he
confidently very very sure of himself
goes on TV stations it with Piers Morgan
BBC ITV channel 4 and oh it says this
book by the way the book is they wanna
this book this one
it teaches people versus they will death
destruction and we keep on pondering
like you ignored you just come out to me
saying he's got nothing to do with Islam
so he's feeling confident he's hopeful
you know ok and after last year when he
called me jihadi and to me it seemed
like Tony Robinson and Britain first you
know this open play field where they
think they can just talk nonsense and
rubbish and lie and lie and get away
with it so often mm-hmm
it's a time to put an end to that so I
want to bring first is watch which you
can see on my channel expose them they
run out the back of the police station
even run me over for some reason they
speak out loud but when you confront
them they go silent
same with Tony Robinson I've been
tracking him down for the past two
months two months I've been asking for
the past year for a debate for the past
two months I've been on this case
properly trying to track him down and we
have a bonus video it's gonna come out
off our pursuit of finding him and
eventually finding him in front of the
County Court now my son of the video is
this I went over it four or five times I
watched I'm chose because it's good to
look into and criticize yourself and say
okay no I could have done better there
and they start my main objective of my
main purpose the goal and see Tony
Robbins
and Britta furs and these lights is that
the fact that they claim Isis and all
these terrorist acts have been happening
it's all because of the Koran Islam so
therefore I thought to myself okay this
is what you claim yeah
now if that's the case then I would like
to ask you some questions because where
are you getting this from right since
you have an open playful thinking you
can do whatever you like
so I eventually trapped him now find the
master begging him for two months please
no discussion literally yeah so
eventually I quotes him eventually I
caught him after waiting at one point I
missed him by inch a Luton Airport yeah
that's another story you'll find out
here so I ended up finding it now what
you might debate with him I got to him
and I say to him a question time yeah
dying to do this Tommy can you please
tell me where in the Quran the hadith
that's secretly source of divine
revelation here the whole Islamic
literature I gave a member for right I
hope enough if 1400 years of Islamic
literature I said Tony please can you
bring me one verse I'm just just just
one verse that says Muslims for you guys
to die as a martyr yeah for you guys to
achieve your ultimate goal of going to
the highest ones of paradise you have to
kill these five Muslims to fire them
non-muslims wherever you find them a
strike of their fingertips and all this
kind of stuff yeah okay now I was
expecting a verse and I did my homework
yeah I did my I went for his book I went
through the tough steer I went for the
historic context its verse all of it so
I'm thinking when I see him he's gonna
come up to me with surah Baqarah verse
192 first or 194 or sort of mind in
verse five to thirty three or sulit all
numbers 1 to verse 13 onwards and surah
Tauba verse 29 the best verses they in
love yet and many other verses yes I'm
thinking they're gonna come up with this
he's gonna come over so I've done my
homework all of them in context yeah so
I must get into question and what I know
they start going to my mom and dad again
yeah don't you like he has this habit of
going personal with people yeah even in
the video at one point he goes oh any
magical Dubai he got clubbin let us
think what do with anything I'm just
really thinking yeah so I asked him over
and over again
thirty-five minutes I asked him produce
is talking this about Hughes tell me
what's gonna dice it up uh I don't know
you can see from his face he was shocked
yeah he was shot he was expectin for me
to come so you can see the desperation
and the levels he went to just to avoid
my question now that's the reason why I
say I exposed him Claire cut because I
went to him with the whole purpose of
you go have interviews of clean stump
teaches violence you have written a book
apparently written a book yet and in
that book you claim it's not a piece of
killing them if I flip them or book now
when I come to you and ask you what she
just imagined ice I claim I know how jet
engines work and some become the system
of the cleavers you and cleaners for the
past ten years
conditional me a single verse that
expect what can you tell me how does the
check engine work how does the plane
flight and I've gone yeah well you know
you're a thief
so the guy's gonna be that one I think
is gonna be the can you tell me how
would you enjoy myself yeah but you know
your dad is a rapist you know I know
about you on Saturdays
go clubbing and have orange juice
they're gonna be like what the hell so
what he did was divert the topic and he
came to ask questions about the
modulation the personalization of Sofia
apostasy rape masturbating on a baby I
know you got cupping and I think what
were you talking about yeah one of those
I've explained in context so we're not
looking at him here I'm thinking you
know thank you
you know that you don't know nothing
yeah because you could have caught
nothing
every time I'll ask no questions just
you'll have it's funny it's quite funny
speaking oh god yeah Easter yeah and
it's got its own phone that's why I
recorded it handle off on my thing on my
channel so people can see clearly
unbiased office I didn't have my phone
be at all
look I'm not sayin question no I want it
to be fair so that so that's why guys I
came to ask you that question but you
could clearly see he dismissed it so
that's why he got fully exposed because
from this day onwards he would never
never I dare him to go and claim yet
that is satisfied
you did not bring a single verse yet oh
you did was personal attack and divert
to the topic and people could clearly
see that people clearly saw right
through you yeah that tell me why you no
answer the question you speak about this
for 10 years 10 years and you could not
bring a single verse and then you do a
video the night off the right the very
night after we had a debate saying all
guys you know because I didn't is
because it says here that you know fitna
means those who don't believe in Allah
and His Messenger so that's why it means
the killing of innocent people rubbish
why did you see that on the day you
would have get exposed you go home and
do a video justifying have you have a
book called why Muslims go for Islam you
go home to do a video to to answer why
you couldn't answer why wasn't your face
now that's exactly what happened so for
my summary the only mistake that I made
was entertain this question besides that
the guys you clearly saw he did not
answer a single question
oh I know many mishaps all personal
attacks yeah all persons have which are
irrelevant to our topic yet anyways so
that's my summary of the video and he
said Monday he said Monday's gonna
release a video he hasn't come he said
Friday we're gonna have an official
debate apparently yeah okay I I bet you
he's not gonna do that
he's not it will be in finished totally
because in a controlled debate you know
what we gonna do bring out at hominins
and these with unrelated topics you're
gonna get demolished yeah okay so
anyways looking forward to that we have
got so what we're doing is now is
because these questions were asked and
we want people to understand the whole
context of everything that he was saying
yeah because he was driving off diverts
most topic Omaha my teacher and startup
nan Rashid and Shyam have made what
we're gonna do is we're gonna discuss
all these claims yeah the marriage of
eyeshot the marriage of Sofia apostasy
and we're going to also talk about this
issue of are flying into heaven the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
flying into heaven only creature yeah
we're going to do that and a lot of
people laugh at this and this is what's
really funny is Christians have beliefs
Christians belief Jesus turned the water
into wine Jews believe and we also
believe as though that Musa al-salaam
parted the seat can you imagine me going
to them and laughing oh you guys it is
this is a belief system and you know
what's really fun
because we have a atheist I don't know
if his natives have forgot us and love
for us because we believe in these
miracles shuttles of what the biggest
fairy tale is the fact that you believe
the whole universe and everything in it
came from nothing if there is God God
can do miracles for his prophets and
anything is possible but if there is no
God
how does nothing come from something so
that's it guys hope you guys have
benefited and this topic of nothing
coming from something I had a really
nice discussion of the Polish eight
field the link is at the end do watch
that hope you guys a benefit look out
for our videos that was my summary leave
your comment on section if there's
anything you want to give me an advice
about thank you take care